Prof: Okay,
so we were talking last time
about rotation in ethane,
and the fact that there was a
barrier,
and that you can measure the
barrier.
And one way to measure the
barrier, the first way that the
barrier was measured,
was remarkably enough,
by the heat capacity of ethane;
how much heat it takes to warm
it to a certain temperature.
So that showed that the barrier
was about three kcal/mole,
but it didn't say what the
geometry of minimum energy was.
Was it eclipsed,
as shown by the red line here,
so that the eclipsed form is
the lowest in energy?
Or was the favored form
staggered?
And people differed in their
interpretation of that.
Ultimately there was some
diffraction study,
electron diffraction,
that showed that it was
staggered.
But now the best word on this
nowadays is probably from really
high-quality calculations.
And you can see from this
paper, published in the
Journal of Chemical
Physics in 2003,
that there's pretty good
agreement.
All these various abbreviations
are various really high-quality
computational results.
You can see at the top,
our experimental results,
from heat capacity.
It's about 1000 wavenumbers.
A wavenumber is 2.86 small
calories, not kilocalories,
per mole.
So there's heat capacity from
infrared spectroscopy,
from microwave,
from Raman spectroscopy.
All these experiments give very
close to 2.9 kcal/mole,
or about 1000 wave numbers --
right?
-- within a couple of percent;
even less than that probably.
And then all these calculations
give about 2.7 kcal/mole.
And it doesn't make very much
difference.
The first one of these -- some
of these aren't such very
high-quality calculations,
but some of them are very,
very high quality,
the best that can be done.
And they all agree pretty much.
So it's clear that the
staggered form is favored over
the eclipsed;
despite what everyone wrote in
the nineteenth century,
when they always wrote them
eclipsed,
and what whoever it was that
drew the picture for the
American Chemical Society of
their Molecule of the Week,
last week, drew too.
He drew it eclipsed;
or she.
Okay?
So anyhow, but then there's the
question why?
Why is it that the staggered
form is lower in energy than the
eclipsed?
Why is there a three
kilocalorie barrier?
Well there's different points
of view on that.
One is that the eclipsed form
is unstable;
that for some reason having it
eclipsed makes it unstable.
The other one is that the
staggered form is unusually
stable.
And what does this remind you
of, in terms of a question?
Students:
Compared to what?
Prof: Compared to what?
What's unusual,
right?
Is what's unusual the eclipsed
form or the staggered form?
Well from the point of view of
the eclipsed form,
why would it be unstable?
Well it could be that the
hydrogens repel one another,
because just in space;
their van der Waals radii.
Okay, but if you think about
that, then if you had a methyl
in place of one of those
hydrogens, it's ever so much
bigger.
Therefore you should have a
much bigger barrier to rotation,
of a methyl group in propane.
But, in fact,
the barrier is almost exactly
the same;
3.4, not ten or something like
that.
So the size of hydrogen doesn't
seem to be so very important.
Of course, protons repel one
another, and the electrons that
are in the bonds repel one
another;
there's electron repulsion.
So that might be why you don't
want to have it eclipsed;
that you want to rotate it a
little bit to make it staggered.
But that's not easy to do in
your head,
because there are also
attractions between a proton on
one side,
and the electron on the other,
and it's not clear which of
these is going to dominate.
So anyhow, there's the
possibility that it has to do
with the eclipsed form being
unusually destabilized -- right?
-- because of repulsions;
that could be.
The other point of view is that
the staggered form is unusually
stable.
Now why could that be?
It's that you have a
σ on one side and a
σ* on the other
side of these C-H bonds;
and vice-versa as well.
And you can get overlap between
this HOMO and LUMO in this way.
And it turns out,
surprisingly enough,
that the overlap is bigger when
they're anti than when they're
eclipsed.
You might think,
intuitively,
that there'd be more overlap
when they're on the same side,
than when they're on the
opposite.
But it doesn't take too much
work to convince yourself that
the other is in fact true,
and that this is the better
overlap.
So you'll get better HOMO/LUMO
interaction from one side to the
other;
and not only for these two
hydrogens,
but for the other two pairs of
hydrogens as well,
if the thing is staggered,
so that the opposite ones are
parallel to one another.
So you can get this kind of
mixing, HOMO/LUMO mixing,
among σ bonds,
which is called
hyperconjugation.
Conjugation is when normal
double bonds,
p orbitals overlap,
from one to the other,
and you get resonance
structure.
The name
"hyperconjugation"
was created to talk about the
same phenomenon when it's
σ bonds,
rather than π bonds
that are doing the trick;
and it's usually much,
much less important.
We'll talk about more examples
of this later on.
But at any rate,
that's a very different point
of view from the first one.
Which is it,
that the eclipsed is
destabilized or that the
staggered is unusually stable?
Or maybe both.
And, in fact,
this is a little bit a
scholastic argument analogous to
how many angels could dance on
the head of a pin;
and you get people that debate
about this.
Right?
So the point is that
fundamentally there's quantum
mechanics that controls this,
but it doesn't say which one of
these things is what.
It doesn't divide it that way.
So some people say one,
some people say the other,
and we'll just say maybe a
little of both.
Okay, now here's a digression
on the question of what's called
"topicity";
which turns out to be relevant
in a lot of biochemical
applications.
So it's worth mentioning at
this point, this aspect of
stereochemistry.
Topicity relates to,
for example,
the question:
are two protons equivalent?
Now at first glance,
that's sort of a stupid
question.
Obviously a proton is a proton,
so they're equivalent.
But suppose one is the H of an
OH group in ethanol,
and the other is an H of the
methyl group.
Now are they equivalent?
Well protons clearly still are
equivalent.
Protons are protons.
What's different about them?
What's different is their
environment.
So it could be that the place
they are is different,
even though the protons
intrinsically are the same,
and therefore they could have
different properties.
Now, that happens to be the
case in ethanol.
An OH group has a pKa of about
16.
It's not very acidic but it's
possible to dissociate H+ and
leave O-.
Right?
But an H that's on a methyl
group doesn't do that.
It has a pKa of about 50.
So it's 10^34th weaker as an
acid, than the OH group.
So there's clearly a difference
between these two hydrogens
because of the place they're in.
Right?
So that the OH on the alcohol
group exchanges readily with
acidic water;
so you can put deuterium in and
out of that, wash it in,
wash it out;
and you can't do that in the
case of methane.
So D+ can come in.
Low LUMO, attacked by the high
HOMO.
You get that.
And then unzip it the other way.
The electrons go back on,
H+ comes off.
So you can do this exchange.
That doesn't happen over on the
other case because it's so hard
to get the proton off,
and the carbon has no unshared
pair to pick up the new proton.
So these two protons,
the red one and the blue one,
the OH and the methyl-H,
are called
"heterotopic";
hetero means different,
and the Greek topos
means place.
So they're in a different place.
They have different properties
because they're in a different
place.
So ‘topicity' comes from
the same root obviously,
and it means the placeness of a
group.
It could be a hydrogen,
it could be another group,
two groups, that appear to be
the same but are in different
places.
So this is a pretty obvious
case.
But there are cases that are
less obvious.
So protons within the blue
group are homotopic,
and the green protons are
homotopic with one another.
Right?
They're in the same kind of
place.
At least they're in the same
kind of place if we're
discussing constitution,
what they're bonded to,
and what those things are
bonded to and so on.
Right?
The nature and sequence of
bonds are obviously the same
between the two green or among
the three blue hydrogens.
And both of those are different
from one another,
and from the red hydrogen.
Okay, so from the point of
constitution,
the blue ones are homotopic,
the green ones are homotopic.
The red one is its own -- right?
-- but the green is heterotopic
with respect to the red or the
blue, and so on.
So that isn't telling you much
that you wouldn't already have
realized easily.
But if you get into
stereochemical topicity,
it gets more subtle.
So let's look at stereotopic
relationships among these
protons.
First, we said that the blue
ones were homotopic.
But are they really homotopic?
Let's consider those two
hydrogens.
Do they have the same
environment?
They're clearly the same with
respect to constitution,
what they're linked to --
right?
-- but are they the same
stereochemically?
Are their environments
superimposable,
exactly on one another?
Yes or no?
So are they stereochemically
homotopic?
Corey, what do you say?
Student:  I'd say yes.
Prof: You say they are?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: If you took the
top hydrogen away,
and looked at everything else,
and then made another model
where you took the bottom one
away,
and looked at everything else,
are those everything elses,
the places, superimposable?
No, they're not,
because one has a hydrogen down
here missing,
and the other one has a
hydrogen up there missing.
You can't superimpose those
unless you do a rotation.
Right?
So that's a question of
conformation,
of rotation,
right?
Okay, so those are
diastereotopic from the point of
--
that is, different places --
from the point of view of
conformation,
but not from the point of view
of >
constitution.
Right?
Sorry, I'm getting my c's
confused.
It's a long run,
from the beginning of September
to Thanksgiving.
You'll find that this will have
been the longest period,
unrelieved period,
of your time at Yale.
It gets easier after this.
Okay, so anyhow they're
diastereotopic from the point of
view of conformation,
but homotopic from the point of
view of constitution.
How about those two?
Do they have the same
environment, those two
hydrogens?
Cathy, what do you say?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: They're
superimposable;
that is, if you took the H in
front away, you'd have a certain
bunch of stuff left;
that's its environment.
And if you took the H in back
away, and looked at the rest of
the stuff, are those two
remainders absolutely identical;
superimposable?
Student:  No.
Prof: What is the
relationship between them?
Obviously that was sort of a
leading question.
Student:  They're mirror
images.
Prof: They're mirror
So what would you call those
two protons?
Student:  Enantiomers.
Prof: Not enantiomers.
It's their places that are
different.
Enantio-what?
Student:  Enantiotopic.
Prof: Enantiotopic.
So the ones at the top are
enantiotopic,
and the first ones we looked at
were diastereotopic.
Right?
Now, do you care?
Is that going to make a
difference in chemistry?
I say no, and the reason I say
no is that it rotates so fast
around a single bond -- we
talked about that last time;
10^10th per second.
And when you rotate,
you exchange one -- one takes
the place of another,
right?
So they exchange places among
themselves faster than almost
anything could happen;
10^10th^( )per second.
So who cares? Right?
So in truth they're
conformationally diastereotopic,
but you don't care about
conformation,
in this case,
because they would rotate so
quickly.
So they're not going to have
experimentally distinguishable
properties, probably,
unless you can look pretty
quick.
Okay?
Now, so these distinctions are
only conformational and erased
by rotation;
in 10^-12 seconds I said here.
Okay?
Yeah, that's more like it.
Okay, now how about the two
green ones?
What's the relationship between
them?
Pat, what do you say?
What's the relationship?
Student:  They're
enantiotopic.
Prof: They're
Now, are they enantiotopic with
respect to conformation?
Can you rotate one and give it
exactly the same place as the
other one?
Student:  No.
Prof: Why not?
What would happen if you tried
to rotate, to put the back green
one in the place of the front
green one?
Student:  It'd change
the location of the OH.
Prof: It would change
Right?
So how could you exchange their
environments?
The only way,
we'd have to break a bond and
put the other hydrogen someplace
else.
So what kind of enantiotopic
are these?
Is it configuration,
conformation,
or constitution,
that you have to change?
Can you do it just by rotation?
Is it just conformation? No.
Do you have to change what's
bonded to what,
to make one?
No.
So it's not -- so it's
configuration,
right?
But the important thing is you
have to break a bond to change
them.
Right?
So that's not going to happen
easily.
So the difference between those
two -- those are also
enantiotopic,
but configurationally
enantiotopic.
So that will last,
that distinction,
in principle,
as long as the bonds endure.
So there's quite a difference.
Those two could be different.
Now let's see if we can see a
case where they're different.
Now that carbon is not a
stereogenic center.
Why is it not a -- how do you
recognized a stereogenic center?
Nate?
Student:  By what it's
attached to -- it's bonded to
four different things.
Prof: You guys shouldn't
sit next to each other.
I was talking to the other Nate.
Student:  It's got two
H's on it.
Prof: Can't hear.
Student:  It's got two
hydrogens on it.
Prof: It's got two
hydrogens.
It has four different things,
right?
And this has two of the same.
But it's called,
for this purpose of topicity
stuff, "prochiral";
that is, it will become chiral
if two of the things that are
the same become different.
For example,
if one of them,
instead of an H,
were a deuterium,
then it would be a chiral
center.
So that thing is called
prochiral.
It would be chiral if the
enantiotopic atoms,
or groups -- it could be
chlorines or it could be methyl
groups or whatever;
if they were made different
somehow, then it would be
chiral.
Now, so in ethanol,
those two green groups are
enantiotopic and
configurationally.
So now "toponymy"
-- that's names of places;
how do we name them?
So we have things -- we have
groups that are constitutionally
homotopic.
They have the same
constitution,
connected to the same things.
Okay, so consider those,
the green hydrogen there,
the light green one in front;
and I'm drawing a Newman
projection also to show it.
We have to be able to give it a
name so people will know what
we're talking about,
when we're -- if this turns out
to be important for some reason.
Okay, so the way we do it is to
assign priority,
if the hydrogens were
different.
Right?
Then we'll be able to call it
R or S,
right?
Because we already have a
scheme for that.
But the two hydrogens would
have to be different.
So let's look at the priority.
OH at that carbon -- the
prochiral carbon -- is obviously
top, and the methyl,
the carbon group attached to
it, is second;
but the two hydrogens come
third and fourth.
But which one should be third
and which one should be fourth?
Now here's the rule.
You give higher priority to the
one that you're naming.
Right?
So if we want to name this one,
we'd give it higher priority
than this one.
So this one will be three and
this one will be four.
So here's the lowest priority.
You can run one to four,
in either direction,
high to low or low to high.
You get the same sense of
handedness.
So let's think about this.
Here we have -- so if I put my
left thumb coming out where this
hydrogen is, the number four,
and curl my fingers,
I go one, two,
three,.
Okay?
So this one would be
left-handed, if it were higher
priority.
Everybody with me on that?
So we'll call that,
not S,
we'll call that hydrogen
pro-S,
because it will become S
-- okay?
-- if we make this -- for
purposes of naming,
when we give it a higher
priority.
Okay?
Now, suppose we look at the
other hydrogen,
that I've shown in the darker
arrow here.
Right?
It obviously is going to be
pro-R,
because the same thing would
run in the opposite direction.
Okay, so pro-R and
pro-S are the name that
you can give to distinguish
groups that are enantiotopic.
Now, is there a reactivity
difference that we would care
about between these groups?
Suppose you bring up a chlorine
atom, and it can attack one or
it can attack the other.
So suppose it attacks the one
on the left.
Right?
Its SOMO mixes with one of the
electrons of the H,
and the other electron on the H
goes on the carbon,
and we break the bond and get
HCl.
This is the first step,
remember, in free radical
substitution.
Or we could do it with the
other one.
What's the relationship between
those two pathways?
Can you see?
The pathway that happens on the
left and the pathway that
happens on the right,
are they the same?
Student:
>.
Prof: Well they're not
superimposable,
okay?
So they're not precisely the
same.
But what are they?
Sophie?
Student:  They're mirror
images.
Prof: They're mirror
images of one another.
Therefore they have the same
energy.
So one will be just as --
remember,
we talked last time about how
fast a reaction goes has to do
with how high an energy you have
to go to, along that path.
Right?
And these are going to be the
same.
So they'll have precisely the
same rates.
So who cares? Okay?
So attacked by a reagent like a
chlorine atom,
those two versions of the
attack, are mirror images,
and thus they're identical in
their rate.
So who cares?
But suppose that you use
something that's handed,
like a right hand,
to pull it off?
Okay?
Now suppose you use the same
right hand to pull the other one
off?
Those aren't mirror images of
one another anymore.
Right?
What do you call -- what's the
relationship between these two
reactions?
What would you call the
relationship between them?
Angela?
Student:  They come out
completely different.
Prof: Can't hear.
Student:  They come out
completely different.
So they're diastereomers.
Prof: Right,
they're diastereomeric paths.
So they're different in energy.
So one will be faster than the
other.
What does that tell you about
the metabolism of ethanol?
If you've got ethanol inside
you, there are things that pull
the hydrogen off and make
aldehyde out of it.
In fact, that's where the name
"aldehyde"
comes from.
Aldehyde is an alcohol that's
been dehydrogenated;
al-de-hyde.
It's interesting, isn't it?
But anyhow, this can be --
would your body,
if your body was trying to
metabolize ethanol,
could it distinguish between
those two hydrogens?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Why?
Who said yes?
Sam?
Student:  Because
whatever enzyme is doing that is
going to be a hand.
Prof: Because the enzyme
that does it is a hand,
a single hand.
Right?
So it will be able to
distinguish between those.
Now, can we prove that? Okay?
So attacks by a resolved chiral
reagent, like an enzyme,
are diastereomeric and should
have different rates.
So horse liver alcohol
dehydrogenase removes only the
pro-R hydrogen from
ethanol.
Pardon me, if it removes only
the pro-R hydrogen in
this deuteroethanol,
it should remove the hydrogen
and never deuterium,
in the case that it's
deuterated like this.
Right?
Messed that up saying it,
but you can read it better than
I can.
Okay?
Now, so that would be a great
experiment.
If you had this compound,
(S)-1-deuteroethanol,
and you reacted it with this
enzyme,
if you always pulled off the H
and left deuteroacetaldehyde,
that would show it was specific.
But if it weren't specific,
then you'd sometimes get one
and sometimes the other coming
off, and you'd get different
acetaldehydes.
Some would have deuterium and
some wouldn't,
left behind.
Okay?
Now what's the problem in doing
this experiment?
Zack?
Student:  How do you
know that deuterium's right
there?
Prof: How do you get the
compound with the deuterium on
only one side in the first
place, so you can do the
experiment?
And this is where there's a
clever way of doing it.
Right?
That would be the reaction,
and you'd get only the
deuterium left and never
hydrogen left,
if it were specific.
So that's a good test,
but where do you get the
starting material?
Now actually,
the alcohol dehydrogenase is a
catalyst, right?
And a catalyst lowers the
energy of the barrier you have
to go through to go across;
lowers the barrier.
But that means it lowers the
barrier in either direction;
because you can go either
direction across this.
Right?
So that means that you can --
this is an oxidation;
removing hydrogen is an
oxidation.
But you could also do the
reverse reaction;
a reduction.
That is, you could start with
this.
So what really does the
oxidation -- LAD is a catalyst
-- what does it is this NAD+
becoming NADH,
taking H- away.
Right?
So if you ran this reaction
backwards,
and started with a deuterium
there,
then if the thing were
specific, you'd put hydrogen
only there,
when you run it backwards;
if it's specific taking it off,
it'll be specific putting it
on.
Right?
Now how would you know if it's
specific, putting it on?
How would you know if it did
that?
How would you know whether,
when it does this reaction,
it scrambles and puts it in
both positions,
and then when you run it
backwards it scrambles and takes
it off both positions,
sometimes one,
sometimes the other;
or whether it's specific going
on and specific coming off?
Lucas, you got an idea?
Student:  You can pull
it off and check optical
activity.
Prof: Ah,
if you could measure the
optical activity of this stuff,
that would be a good way of
doing it.
But it doesn't have very much
optical activity,
if the only difference is
between deuterium and hydrogen;
not very much.
Student:  This is just
kind of guess,
but if they did it to both
things, wouldn't you get one
with both and then one with only
one?
And then if it only went to one
side, you'd only get one with
one.
Prof: I think you said
it.
Student:  Probably not
right.
Prof: But I don't know
that everyone understood what
you said.
The idea is do both.
Put on, and then take that
product and take it off again.
If it's specific going on,
and specific going off,
when you go through the whole
cycle you'll get back where you
started from.
But if it mixes up going on and
coming off, then sometimes it
will put it on the wrong place,
sometimes it will take it off
the wrong place.
And when you come back,
sometimes you'll have H and
sometimes you'll have D,
in that starting material.
Right?
So you go both ways and see.
And that works, right?
By starting with the same
catalyst and excess deuteride,
you do that,
to go that way.
Okay?
So if you do a full cycle,
like that, then you come back
-- pardon me -- you come back
exactly where you started.
But, this proves the
specificity;
but it doesn't say which one,
it doesn't say whether it was
pro-R or pro-S.
For that you need to do other
kinds of experiments that we
don't have time to talk about.
Okay?
So that's really a neat
experiment,
that shows that topicity makes
a difference,
and that enzymes discriminate
between stereotopic,
enantiotopic groups, or atoms.
Okay, next subject is Baeyer
Strain Theory,
which was proposed in 1885.
So that's ten years after van't
Hoff.
Okay?
So here's the group in Munich,
in 1893, and here,
front and center,
is the boss of the group,
Adolf von Baeyer.
And this picture hangs in the
hallway out there,
the original picture.
You can look at it.
And the reason it does is that
this guy here is Henry Lord
Wheeler.
Did you ever see his name?
Student:
>.
Prof: See how observant
you are.
Student:
>.
Prof: Pardon?
Lexy, did you -- Pat?
Student:  Is it down in
the foyer to this building?
Prof: Yeah,
when you come in,
there are these names carved on
the walls,
which were the people who were,
in the nineteenth,
early-twentieth century,
professors.
So he was the first organic
chemist at Yale,
and he went to Munich,
where a lot of people went to
learn organic chemistry from
Baeyer.
Baeyer, remember,
was the guy who fiddled with
the bread rolls,
together with Fischer,
to make these models.
He was also the guy that did
experiments on arsenic in
Kekulé's kitchen when he
was a student.
So Baeyer was the leading
organic chemist of the time.
Now, in 1885 he -- that's
earlier than this picture;
that picture was 1893,
when Henry Lord Wheeler was
there.
Notice that he died at what;
at thirty-seven,
the age of thirty-seven.
I don't know what he died of,
in 1911.
So he wasn't a professor very
long.
Okay, so this paper,
eight years earlier,
was about polyacetylene
compounds;
so a bunch of triple bonds
arranged in a row.
We've talked about double bonds
in a row;
you can have triple bonds in a
row too.
But you don't have them for
very long because,
as Baeyer reported in this
paper, they explode.
He had a collaborator named
Dr. Homolka,
who he thanks for doing some of
the experiments in this paper.
Dr. Homolka does not appear
in the 1893 picture.
>
I suspect that he just
graduated, got his degree and
went to be gainfully employed
someplace.
But who knows?
Anyhow, polyacetylenes are
explosive.
And this got Baeyer thinking,
why should just a regular old
hydrocarbon be explosive?
So he branched out in this
paper, and the very first topic
was "The Theory of Ring
Closure and the Double
Bond."
Now that seems a funny thing to
talk about;
when you're talking about
triple bonds,
to talk about making rings,
and talk about double bonds.
But what he says is:
"Ring closure"
which was a popular synthetic
goal,
at that time,
to make new kinds of compounds,
was to try to make rings.
They could make six-membered
rings, they could make
five-membered rings.
In Bayer's lab they actually
made four-membered rings and
three-membered rings,
right?
Although that was quite a chore.
Okay, so "Ring closure is
apparently the only phenomenon
that can supply information
about the arrangement of atoms
in space."
This is ten years after van't
Hoff.
"Since a chain of five or
six members can be closed
easily,
while one of more or fewer
members is difficult or
impossible,
spatial factors are apparently
involved."
And you know,
we already talked about a case
like this, where you tell
something about arrangement in
space from the ability to form a
ring.
Do you remember what that is?
Anybody? Yeah?
Student:  Synthesis of
mesitylene.
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  Synthesis of
mesitylene.
Prof: Oh,
the synthesis of mesitylene
formed a ring.
But that doesn't -- so he used
that to say where the methyl
groups were on the ring.
And that's actually a good
example, but it's not the one I
was thinking about.
Student: Cyclopropane.
Student:  Cyclopropane?
Prof: Dichloropropane?
Student:  No.
Prof: Is that what you
said?
Student:  No,
I said cyclopropane with the
>.
Prof: It's not
cyclopropane that I had in mind;
although that was one of the
compounds that was synthesized
in Baeyer's lab for the first
time, and found to be reactive.
But there was another occasion.
Remember maleic and fumaric
acid;
one was cis and one was
trans?
And the one that was cis
could lose water to form a ring.
Right?
So that was what he's referring
to here.
Okay, so then he goes on to
say: "The previously --
" (So there's a website you
can click on to see this.)
"The previously proposed
general rules on the nature of
carbon atoms are the following:
I.***Carbon is
tetravalent."
Who did that?
Student:  Couper and
Kekulé.
Prof: Couper and
Kekulé,
right?
"The four valences are
equivalent, shown by the fact
there's only one
monosubstitution product of
methane."
(We've talked about that.)
"III.
The valences are equivalently
arranged in space to the corners
of a regular tetrahedron."
Who says that carbon is
tetrahedral?
Student:  van't Hoff.
Prof: van't Hoff.
Also, incidentally,
there was a Frenchman who did
it simultaneously,
called LeBel.
Okay?
"IV.
The atoms or groups attached to
the four valences cannot
exchange places."
(So you can't -- you have to
break bonds to make new isomers,
right?
So if you get them one way,
they'll stay.)
"The evidence is that
there are two tetrasubstitution
products, abcd of methane."
(So van't Hoff and LeBel's
rule, that you can have
configurational enantiomers,
we would say.)
"V.
Carbon atoms can bond to one
another with one,
two, or three valences."
(That is, you have single,
double, triple bonds.)
"VI.
The compounds can form either
open chains or rings."
(That's what he's talking about
here.)
"I should like to add the
following, to these generally
accepted rules.
So he's adding a new property,
to the models,
the same way van't Hoff did;
van't Hoff added arrangement in
space, to the models that people
already drew.
What Baeyer is adding is VII.)
"The four valences of the
carbon atom point to the
directions connecting the center
of the sphere to the corners of
a tetrahedron."
(That's what van't Hoff also
said -- already said.)
"But forming an angle of
109°28' with one
another."
(That's very quantitative and
precise.
That's the angle between the
center and two vertices in a
geometric regular tetrahedron.
Okay?)
But then this is what's
interesting: "The direction
of attachment can undergo
alteration"
(It doesn't have to be exactly
that angle) "but a
strain is generated,
increasing with the size of the
deflection."
So if you have an angle other
than 109°28',
then there's going to be higher
energy associated with strain;
or, what he's actually talking
about is not higher energy,
but reactivity.
Okay, so he drew this picture,
showing how much the angles are
distorted from 109.5°.
So if you consider ethylene to
be a two-membered ring,
with two bent bonds,
the angle the bonds are going
at is where it should be
tetrahedral;
and in fact they're collinear.
That distortion of each bond is
54°44', and so on,
for three, four;
five is perfect, right?
It only deviates by 44'.
But the six-membered ring is
stretched a little bit the other
way.
It has to go out,
rather than sharper.
Okay.
So he says:
"Dimethylene…"
--
that's ethylene,
the first one --
"…is indeed the
weakest ring,
which can be opened by HBr,
bromine,
or even iodine."
(We talked about bromine,
or chlorine attacking the
ethylene already.)
"Trimethyle
ne…"
(cyclopropane) "…is
broken only by hydrogen bromide
but not by bromine."
(So it's not as reactive as the
two-membered ring.)
"Finally,
tetramethylene and
hexamethylene are difficult or
impossible to break."
They're pretty stable.
So this strain causes
reactivity, if the bond angles
aren't right.
So he's becoming more
quantitative;
unusually quantitative for an
organic chemist at this period.
Remember, the physical chemists
-- this is just at the period
when physical chemistry is
coming into its own --
and they were the ones who did
heat and energy and so on.
All Baeyer is talking about is
whether things will react or
not.
But he's using geometric
precision.
Okay?
So the question is,
are six-membered rings,
like this, cyclohexane,
they should be,
according to Baeyer,
a little bit strained.
Right?
Because the angles should be --
you'd think the angles would be
120° instead of 109.
So they're opened up a little
bit too much.
But Sachse, a young
privatdocent -- that is,
essentially,
between a graduate student and
a professor --
in 1890 published a paper that
had this very funny picture,
A,B,C,D,E,F,
up on the top there.
And people didn't understand
what it was.
But what it is,
is a thing that if you trace it
on cardboard and fold along the
diagonals, you get this blue
thing -- right?;
if you fold it along the
diagonals and paste the ends
together.
Right?
And then if you paste van't
Hoff tetrahedra on it,
you get this thing.
And you'll see that this is
just like this.
Everybody see that?
It's using -- but this is a
base on which to build such
tetrahedral carbons,
so as to make this structure.
And what's interesting about it
is that these angles are the
normal tetrahedral angles.
Right?
They're not strained. Right?
Why are they not 120°?
Because the ring isn't flat,
it's puckered.
Okay?
So that's what Sachse said.
And he gave people this thing
so they could make their own
models and see it.
Right?
And he gave the directions for
building this more complicated
base, where you put it on and
have a different form of
cyclohexane.
Okay?
And that one,
as you see, looks like this.
Okay?
So in 1890 he knew exactly the
score that we would know -- that
we would get with our own models
nowadays.
Now, when this was abstracted
in the journal that published
abstracts of all chemical
literature so people could go
there and find out what was
going on in chemistry,
Julius Wagner,
who abstracted it,
said: "It is not possible
to write an abstract of this
paper,
especially since the author's
explanations are hardly
understandable,
without models."
Now, one conclusion from that
should be therefore go and build
his models and look at them,
and you'll see what he's
talking about.
But that's not what Wagner
said, and it's not what people
did.
He said, "Forget that,
it's nonsense"
-- right?
-- "you can't understand
it." Okay.
So Baeyer wasn't happy with
this, disputing his theory.
So he wrote,
in the same year,
1890 --
Sachse wasn't too smart about
this because he published that
paper just as they were having a
big celebration of Baeyer's
contributions to aromatic
chemistry in Berlin;
there was this big,
fabulous dinner with eighteen
courses, or something like that,
and all -- everybody,
chemists from all over Germany
gathered.
And Sachse, this nobody,
publishes a paper and says
Baeyer's theory is wrong.
Bad timing.
So Baeyer published a response
quickly.
He said: "A further
proposal is that the atoms in
hexamethylene…"
(six-CH_2 groups,
cyclohexane) "…are
arranged as in Kekulé's
model."
(Now Kekulé's model,
remember, by this time was in
fact a tetrahedron;
which is what Sachse showed how
you could do it.
Right?)
But he says,
"…as in
Kekulé's model,
and that the arrangement of the
atoms in space is one with
minimum distortion of the
valence directions."
(That sounds like Sachse.)
But what he says is:
"Thus, the six carbon
atoms must lie on one
plane."
(It's got to be planar.)
"and six hydrogen atoms
lie in equidistant parallel
planes."
(Six above, six below.
All the CH_2s are just like
this around the ring.
Right?)
"Further,
each of the twelve hydrogen
atoms must have the same
position relative to the other
seventeen."
(That is, they're homotopic;
you can rotate it,
if the plane is flat.
Now how can he say this?
It's not really like
Kekulé's model.
Okay?)
"The experimental test of
the correctness of this
assumption is relatively easy;
for example sufficient evidence
is that there is a single isomer
of hexahydrobenzoic acid."
That this, only one cyclohexane
carboxylic acid.
That is, if you had this,
and put a COOH group here,
or a COOH group here,
what would be the relationship
between those?
This place and this place,
what would you call -- are they
homotopic?
Are they enantiotopic,
this place and this place?
Mirror images?
No, they're just different.
They're diastereotopic, right?
Now, but you could do a neat
trick.
So that's what he says.
If it were like Sachse,
then you'd have two isomers of
a monosubstituted cyclohexane.
But what he didn't take into
account was this.
This one is sticking up like
that.
Watch this.
Notice the black one is
sticking out,
down at an angle,
and the white one is sticking
straight up.
But watch this.
Now this one's down at an angle
and the black one's straight up.
Did I break any bonds?
What did I do?
Student:  Rotated.
Prof: I just rotated
about bonds.
They're conformational;
conformationally diastereotopic.
Not configurationally.
So they're different but they
can interconvert easily.
Right?
So Baeyer says he's right
because there's only one isomer,
so you have to regard it as
flat, even if it isn't;
although he didn't say that.
"Meanwhile,
as long as our knowledge in the
field is so incomplete,
we must be satisfied that the
above assumption is the most
likely,
and no known fact contradicts
it." Okay?
Now, Sachse didn't take this
lying down either.
So he publishes a forty-one
page paper in Zeitschrift
für Physikalische
Chemie,
which is published by Ostwald,
who hates Baeyer,
and vice-versa;
the physical chemists and the
organic chemists didn't get
along.
So he publishes a paper in this
other one where he gives all
this trigonometry to explain
what he means by this structure.
Is this something calculated to
appeal to organic chemists?
Not very likely. Okay?
So this is edited by Ostwald,
who didn't even believe in
atoms,
remember, and wrote
disparagingly of his successor
in Riga,
who had been an organic
chemist: "Scientifically,
he had been brought up in the
narrow circle of contemporary
organic chemistry,
and to him the arrangement in
space of the atoms of organic
compounds was the foremost of
all conceivable problems."
That wasn't what Ostwald
thought was the best problem.
So Sachse published again.
Nobody responded to that first
one, so he publishes again,
the next year,
thirty-four pages again.
And here he gives more formulas;
again, things that didn't
appeal at all to anybody who was
actually interested in the
arrangement of atoms in space.
And then he died at the age of
thirty-one, in that year,
and that was the end of Sachse,
and the end of his theory.
Right?
And Baeyer wrote in 1905 -- so
twelve years later:
"Sachse disagreed with my
opinion that larger rings are
planar.
He is certainly right from a
mathematical point of
view;"
(Although I sort of doubt that
Baeyer went through every line
of this to check it.
Right?)
"Yet, in reality,
strangely enough,
my theory appears to be
correct.
The reason is not clear."
Okay?
So that was -- remember,
Sachse was 1890.
So what important lesson should
we take from the tale of poor
Sachse?
Do you want me to give you that
as a problem to think about over
Thanksgiving?
Fine.
Okay, so this,
remember is what Sachse wrote,
and he drew models like this.
And -- I'll just conclude the
punch line here --
in 1913 Bragg and Bragg
determined the diamond
structure,
by X-ray diffraction of a
crystalline diamond.
Right?
And five years later,
Ernst Mohr published a diagram
he drew of -- from that diamond
structure.
Braggs didn't draw the
structure, but Mohr did five
years later.
And here's what he drew,
and that is exactly what Sachse
meant.
Right?
So the arrangement of the
carbons in a six-membered ring,
in diamond, is exactly what
Sachse said;
but he got nothing for it.
Okay, have a good Thanksgiving.